Republicans are looking to phase out
electric vehicles
why on Earth would they do that because
they want to defend and support to the
death the oil and gas industry let's
look at a couple of reports Newsweek
reporting Republicans want to phase out
electric cars to protect fossil fuels in
late December Oregon officials approved
regulations that would ban the sale of
new gas powered vehicles in the state by
2035. that's pretty interesting two
states away in Wyoming Republican
lawmakers are looking to go in a
different direction rights Newsweek
pushing legislation that would ban the
sale of all new electric vehicles in
what lawmakers are calling an effort to
preserve the state's fossil fuel
industry what
sponsored by Casper Republican senator
Jim Anderson with the support of other
Republicans the resolution proposes to
phase out the sale of all new electric
vehicles in the state by 2035 to help
maintain the fossil fuel jobs that
underpin the state's economy imagine I
have Contraband I went to another state
to get it what is it is it is it meth
what is it is it the abortion pill
no it's an electric vehicle
huh that's pretty bonkers the
proliferation of electric vehicles reads
the resolution at the expense of gas
powered vehicles will have a deleterious
in will have deleterious impacts on
Wyoming's communities and will be
detrimental to Wyoming's economy and the
ability for the country to efficiently
engage in Commerce they're just going to
say you can't buy electric vehicles
anymore not new and Gadget reporting
Wyoming wants to phase out sales of new
EVS by 2035. it's a symbolic gesture
aimed at States like California
California New York of course are going
in the direction of saying after a
certain date we're not going to allow
ice Vehicles internal combustion engine
vehicles to be sold so a couple thoughts
first of all this is not exactly the
free market now you could say electric
vehicles shouldn't be subsidized you
could say that you could take that you
could make that argument and say listen
um I really want a free market so the
government shouldn't offer rebates or
tax credits on electric vehicles now if
that's your position you should also say
that the government shouldn't subsidize
oil and gas fossil fuels at all right if
your position is no subsidies let the
free market decide you've got to get rid
of all subsidies and tax credits that
that is certainly one position but it is
not a free market to say phase out
electric vehicles but continue
subsidizing oil and gas which is exactly
what they want to do now you can make
arguments about electric vehicles that I
think are perfectly Fair arguments to
make like for example the sourcing of
some of the materials required to make
batteries is a problem I'm with you it's
got to be figured out there is no doubt
I believe it's Cobalt the sourcing of
cobalt for Batteries is a problem we
have to figure out what do we do with
spent electric vehicle batteries that
question is being answered it's being
worked on it's going to be figured out
but you have to remember that there are
some systemic fundamental advantages to
electric vehicles over gas powered
vehicles that make this
I I would never say this is the end
point once electric vehicles are
predominant there will be some next
thing right 100 years two three five
hundred years this isn't the end but
when you compare electric to gas powered
gas-powered Vehicles typically have
what's called energy conversion
efficiency of 20 that means 20 percent
of the energy stored in the gasoline
before you burn it is actually used to
power the vehicle 20 that's very low
electric vehicles have an energy
conversion efficiency of 90 meaning that
90 of the energy stored in the batteries
is actually used to power the vehicle to
power its systems to move the vehicle at
the base level
electric vehicles are way more efficient
at using energy and they produce fewer
emissions now then you get to the next
layer benefit electric vehicles don't
have a tailpipe they don't emit
pollutants and greenhouse gases at the
tailpipe gas-powered Vehicles as they
drive around
spew dangerous pollutants like carbon
monoxide nitrogen oxides particulate
matter also all sorts of stuff terrible
for human health terrible for the
environment electric vehicles don't do
that there's no tailpipe emissions they
don't directly pollute the air now of
course
where's the electricity coming from the
electricity may be polluting the air but
you can get off of that you can power
your electric vehicle with solar energy
with wind energy and so every time you
go up up up the chain you reduce the
emissions and the benefit of electric
vehicles over gas powered vehicles grows
now
we still have problems to solve
but these are fundamental realities and
these Republicans I mean listen even the
uh Legacy automobile manufacturers are
realizing the direction things are going
they're trying to roll out the EVS
slowly right they still want to get as
much money out of ice Vehicles as they
can but even GM and Ford and all these
companies realize the way things are
going but Republicans some retrograde
Republicans are saying no no no no we're
not going to do it it is absolutely
horrifying and they don't actually care
you know this is like saying we don't
believe that smoking is bad let's have
this movement to maintain smoking in
restaurants that we've seen
um
the companies that for 40 years have
known that uh the harvesting of fossil
fuels is bad for the environment and
they cover up or they pretend they don't
know about it whatever the case may be
it is not only immoral in the long term
I actually think it's bad business but
the state of Wyoming says let's phase it
out
um it will be laughed at eventually I
don't know if it'll be five years from
now 10 20. it will be seen as absolutely
absurd that states once we have the
technology we're building out the
charging Network that states we're still
saying hey let's protect the cars that
drive around burning fossil fuels
putting it into the atmosphere
furthering the negative impact of the
entire fossil fuel industry it will be
seen as insane uh when I don't know but
Wyoming wants to wants to lead the world
in that it's disgusting let's take a
quick break and we'll be back after this